you've been working on this book for
quite a long time it's not like you
you okay moderator me the president said
hey I should quickly write a book about
president writing this book about the
president since he got elected man take
a note smaller the book is critical of
the president I mean area I'm not saying
that you're I think it's a I think it's
a I think it's a it's neither I'll I say
it's neither a liberal defense or
conservative attack it's right sort of
what I saw yes your there are positive
things there are negative things in the
book do you get nervous that okay you
put this book out you've interviewed the
president you're the moderator for the
press that he'll read the book or hear
about some of the negative things I am
NOT looking forward to the next time I
see him I know you know where you may
say hey you know about that one thing
you wrote about you know you didn't take
into account this this this and this and
you know it can be intimidating thing
that said I wanted to interview him for
the book and yeah and his staff said no
in your book you say Obama and Hillary
kind of like each other which is
something I maybe would not have assumed
is true I think everybody assumes they
don't but yeah them like each other a
lot more sometimes in the old staffs you
know a lot of times in campaigns
it's the stabs that hate each other
because they when they were campaigning
against each other the stabs are working
so hard to write very Gemini's and all
this stuff the two of them have this
interesting bond I think part of it is
sort of the bond it's almost like
they've been to war together you know
you can only the only other person that
understands what's it what it's like to
be a candidate to be in a bubble to be
point you know to be to be an official
like that is is her or her to him and
all this stuff so they have this
interesting bond in it I think it's
through it sort of throws his staff off
sometimes like they'll go in there and
they share inside jokes and like but
you're not supposed to be that friendly
you know we keep telling people that
you're not that friendly but they're
there oddly they're oddly very close
come people come in and they're playing
twister left hand yellow
Wow okay he's a funny guy too
yeah that's the sense I've in the times
that I've gotten to interact with him I
get this he's very quick he is so we've
got a good ironic sense of humor no I'll
give you a given example so my wife's
name is Christian it's spelled Kri STI
and she was supposed to be a boy right
so they'd you know her mom just gave her
girl's name well we're in the White
House photo line during Christmas we go
up to him
and she introduced her hi mr. president
my name is Christian and goes hi I'm a
Muslim and my wife is mortified oh my
god did he think I was like seeing a
statement he knows my first name is
really Christian right and all this
stuff and he like looked at me and gave
me a wink it was it was a funny joke but
he's very quick yeah I I have a younger
brother Justin who and the whole I was
always teasing him he's my younger
brother always giving him a hard time
and then when I did the White House
correspondent or a few years ago he I
invited him and my Justin and his wife
and they got to meet the president and
the president meets Justin and and he
looks and the first thing he does and
he's he's so cool and detached he looks
at Justin looks at me and goes like
Conan your brother
good-looking how'd that happen thank you
in front of everybody and my brother was
so happy that he finally got his car
back finally from the guy he got the big
guns in hey older brother go ahead right
yeah finally stick it to you
you